est ce que l'on nous suivraient toujours
oui
sera-t-il seul nous regardons at-il
aurait-il une seule main posée sur le
volant au moindre bruit
évoquant un coup de feu démarré
à
très joli
nous avons il y à peu découvert
l'existence d'une organisation
criminelle internationale liés à
d'anciens nazis
la rumeur veut qu'ils aient conçus une
boule atomique nous n'avons pas d'autre
choix que celui de collaborer afin
d'infiltrer cette organisation nous vous
laissons faire connaissance tous les
deux
napoléon solo voilà donc le plus doué
des agents de la cia
yakou rien kid koala dont le cadet du
kgb devenu leur meilleur élément en
moins de trois ans
l'amérique fait équipe avec la russie
cela sent l'embrouillé oui l'ennui c'est
que je travaille mieux c'est moi aussi
je travaille mieux ce bond mais ne
m'entendrez pas
avez vous une invitation mon cocktail
jeu les volets un volet j'espère que
vous avancer masqué cela m'arrive mais
jamais en plein vol
vous n'êtes pas très fort sur la
subtilité n'est ce pas
il va rester comme ça environ 20 minutes
attention pas tout vous allez avoir
droit aux la fessée ou les constate non
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit après
voulait
à koudougou ouest
pour un agent spécial votre journée
n'est pas très spécial n'est ce pas
vous appartiennent ou sont elles à moi